hi I'm Alexis Rivas and I'm the
co-founder and CEO of cover cover is
developing the building block of the
future what does this mean today it
means backyard homes built in days in
the future entire cities built at a
speed never seen
before that will
require a new real estate system driven
by software
the building block of the future enables
us to build 10 times
faster what is this building block it's
a set of wall panels floor panels and
ceiling panels you can think of them
like life-size Lego blocks that come
together to make your home they come
with insulation waterproofing Electrical
Plumbing everything installed from the
factory they're flat packed shipped on
site on a regular truck and then rapidly
assembled it's a complete system which
means it has the finishes the kitchen
the bathroom everything that you need
for a fully functional home from the
factory and this is real we built this
backyard home in 8
days we're starting off with backyard
homes to validate the system on a small
scale first and then once we nail it
we'll scale it
and you can see there's no big cranes
required no big uh equipment it's all
lightweight easy to come together and
this is what it looks like when it's
done this here is actually the 15th
cover that we built I actually lived in
this one for over a year absolutely
loved it the only reason I moved out
because it was a really long commute for
LA and you can visit this one just email
us hello cover. uild cover.com and you
can check out the virtual tour using
that
link We obsess over the details to prove
that this is a better way to live not
just a faster way to
build you see those Flor to ceiling
Windows those are true Flor to ceiling
Windows the kinds of details that you
normally see in multi-million dollar
homes historically prefab has earned a
reputation for being lowcost and poor
quality we're disproving that cover
homes are highend and as we ramp up
production we'll lower the cost and
we'll make the mass
Market these here are two different
cover homes miles apart built from the
same
panels you can see with this finite set
of panels we can make a virtually
infinite number of different
designs
and backyard homes are just the start
the same panels will be used to build
larger
structures primary homes with two
stories and multif family buildings for
hundreds of people to live
in modular construction allows cities to
easily and quickly
adapt a building like this 300 units for
hundreds of people can be built in just
3 to 4 months with consistent
quality and then once that built it
doesn't have to be a static building it
can evolve to meet changing
needs compare that with conventional
buildings which are fixed in place when
demand shifts they're abandoned or
demolished you can't recoup much value
from them whereas with modular you can
take those panels apart refurbish them
and turn them into a completely new
building somewhere else as
needed so now let's talk a little bit
about the regulatory side of this
prefab systems will be approved for
Building Code Compliance at a system
level eliminating the need for building
code approvals for each building this is
necessary so that we can build fast
we're already doing part of this in
California and then at a larger scale
the software itself that configures the
panels into a building will be
pre-approved uh to enable fast
permitting so building code approvals
are the easier because they're focused
on building safety which is relatively
objective zoning on the other hand is
harder much harder it answers questions
like should we build this Tower in the
middle of a neighborhood that doesn't
have any other tall
structures now today what you can build
on your property is controlled by zoning
when you when you buy a property
typically it doesn't mean you can build
absolutely anything you want you can't
build a mine you can't build uh you know
you know super tall skyscraper it's
controlled typically by what the city
says that you can build this you can
think of it like a volume that the city
says this is what you can
build this is
zoning unfortunately that raises the
question you know what what does that
mean in terms of when that envelope that
you can build within can change who can
change it why can you change how can it
change it's a bureaucratic timeconsuming
and unpredictable process to change
zoning and discretionary exceptions are
given to some and not others now this is
where it gets really interesting and I
actually worked on this for my thesis in
2016 a new system of real estate will be
needed that's driven by software in
order to be able to keep up with
construction that's 10 times faster and
at the center of that new system is that
we will negotiate space without
intermediaries so what does that mean
how do we actually do that
so the first thing is we've got to turn
the the spatial traits that we value
such as views privacy and light into
property rights these are actually
quantifiable properties you can see here
with views if you have a thicker
structure how it changes when you go to
a thinner structure or privacy from one
building to the other or how light moves
throughout the space both direct and
indirect light and how that's imp acted
by other structures so you take these
things that we care about and that today
are managed with zoning you quantify
them and you turn them into property
rights that can be
traded and then you trade these
directly how you upload a digital model
of the proposed change to an
authentication system which
identifies whose rights are impacted by
the proposed
change and then once you you negotiate
it through an exchange and once you
agree then you start building and what
this allows is cities of the future to
evolve at a pace that'll match the
construction that we're doing at
cover so just to
recap the building block of the future
enables us to build 10 times faster and
we're already doing this at
cover with that building block modular
cities will be able to quickly and
easily adapt to
change and a new system of real estate
will be needed so that space can be
negotiated without intermediaries and
our cities can keep up with the change
that's
needed if you're interested in building
this future with us please reach out
thank
you